[Musique]
à quelques jours du réveillon de la
saint sylvestre le conseil départemental
organisé un marché pays ce mercredi 28
décembre jardin de l'état l'occasion
pour les réunionnais d'acheter des
produits de qualité pour l'heure pas
défaut mais aujourd'hui c'est surtout le
foie gras magrets de toutes sortes de
foie gras
ça permet que les retardataires qui
n'ont pas acheté ce jour marché ou qui
ne sont pas commandés profitent pour
acheter aujourd'hui
et d'ailleurs si pratiquement la plus
probable nouvelle et sa mousse à base de
parmi ces cocos des varois et puis il ya
les salles a permis ce qu'ils veulent
entendre ap la barre ce soit en morceaux
pour faire car il adore le lâche à
arriver en fin d'année c'est c'est le
produit qui vont très bien
on a acheté sa bosse à palm hills des
très très beau et puis là on va chez du
palmiste pour rapper nous mêmes parce
qu'il ya trop la queue et on va rapper
offense à la drogue juste titre ont été
produits pour les fêtes unis également
l'occasion de découvrir une nouvelle
variété de plantes grâce à jean frey qui
participe à son premier marché plié ben
c'est des nénuphars des lotus après tout
ce qui pourra pratiquer de la praye
d'étals ya des comptes est d ailleurs
assez tout ce qui est lié aux bas
salaires
maintenant tout ce que des pièces de me
dire elle à la mode dans les bassins de
rio
l'un parce que je suis à peine ni voter
mais comme ça dépote le dire elle a pas
besoin d'entretien ce n'est pas tout
dire il vit dans l'eau d'arrosage n'a
pas une maladie il craqua cyclone un
marché pays devenu incontournable et un
concept qui prend toute sa place
aujourd'hui dans la relation
consommateurs producteurs ce circuit
court est essentielle
on revient à des choses simples à des
choses basiques qu'on avait connue dans
l'ancien temps et aujourd'hui
effectivement je vois que le
consommateur prend goût à être en
contact avec celui qui produit ce qui va
manger ce qui va mettre dans son
assiette
donc c'est un moment essentiel moment de
convivialité où on apprend aussi à se
connaître à échanger à discuter c'est le
lien social que crée le département la
jeune anglaise du département est en
effet de continuer à privilégier cette
proximité entre le consommateur et le
producteur
rendez vous l'année prochaine pour
d'autres marchés ping
[Musique]